[Music]
hey everyone uh I'm Nick I'm an engineer
at Super dial and first of all big
thanks to the organizers this event has
been awesome I've had a blast talking to
you guys connecting with you guys and
hearing all these great talks um some
I'm one of the few voice AI talks today
in this weekend so I have a lot to cover
we're going to Dive Right In if you're
new to voice AI I hope I can provide a
nice little framework to think about
this very fast moving space and if
you're building with voice AI already
I'll be sharing some little anecdotes
from our own scaling Journey that I hope
will help yours as well so voice AI in
2025 extremely exciting we're seeing
these new smart really fast really
affordable llms that are supporting a
lot more complex conversational use
cases uh but you still kind of need some
tricks to take your chat agent and turn
it into a voice agent we have these low
latency really realistic super
generative textto speech models but
sometimes we have audio hallucinations
and we have to deal with things like
pronunciation and
spelling with all the new things that
people are building there's this
explosion in voice aai infrastructure
and tooling and evaluation systems and a
big question becomes what's actually
worth owning
and the big one on everyone's mind are
these new speech to speech or voice too
models uh and our take is that for a lot
of production applications they're not
quite yet ready and a big reason for
that is they start to Output things that
aren't actually speech aren't actually
uh things that you can use to build a
reliable conversation and this we saw
this when they first came out they were
like imitating people's voices and from
the start that's why we've kind of been
favoring uh reliability over this sort
of realism so today I'm going to talk
about how we at Super dial approach
agents as a service how we think about
the voice AI engineer and The Last Mile
problem so once you have your little
voice uh MVP all the challenges that
you're going to face trying to actually
make it reliable and put it to
work so at Super dial we're in the
business of phone calls specifically one
of the most annoying phone calls ever
that phone call to your insurance
company so for Mid to large-sized
healthcare administration businesses we
sell the super di platform and with
super dial you can build your script so
design the sort of conversation ask all
the questions that you need to get
answered over the phone you send us your
calls via CSV API or we also integrate
with a lot of EHR software systems and
then you know within the next couple
hours in the next day we send you back
your results in a stretched format and
this makes for a really interesting
agentic contract that we sort of have
with our customers so from their
perspective they're paying for results
they tell us who to call which questions
to ask and we tell them the answers
internally we have a little agentic Loop
set up so
that uh we go out we wait for these
offices to be open we wait for um you
know the call centers to open so we can
actually make these calls we will
attempt to make the call with our voice
bot and then if our voice spot needs to
bring in a human to complete the call or
cannot complete the call after a certain
number of attempts then we send it to a
fallback team and this is something that
of course we're transparent with with
our customers in fact it's a benefit to
them because it's kind of inevitable
with these Healthcare phone calls that
sometimes you need to bring in a human
so with us they know that no matter what
happens the call will get made whether
or not it gets made with a human or a
bot doesn't matter to them they get
their answers reliably and in a
structured
format uh and with all these calls we
try to do our best to learn from them so
we'll update the sort of office hours
for the given phone number we're calling
and learn from the sort of phone tree
traversal that we just tried so when we
call it again we get even better at that
sort of call and because there are
sensitive Healthcare phone calls we want
to make sure our system always works so
randomly we'll take out some of these
calls audit them make sure everything's
working uh for a quick little demo this
is actually a prior authorization call
uh this this is after the point where
we've traversed little phone tree by
clicking the right buttons and now we're
talking to a human and trying to get
some questions answered for a customer I
know your first
name hi this is
Sarah are you calling from a doctor's
office or from a
facility I'm calling from provider's
Office do you have a member ID or a case
number the member ID is
what is the CPT
code the CPT codes are
81243 okay hold
on so there's a Kon file uh that was
initiated for the code
81243 it is pending so this case number
is and we have not received any
clinicals for this case
yet okay what is your name again and
what is the reference number for this
call my first theme is you may have the
pending case number as a call reference
number and the fact number on where to
send a clinicals
is thanks so much for your
help you're welcome thanks for calling
have a great
day so that's it uh if that call was
really boring to you
than if that call was really boring
that's kind of just how these things go
a boring call for us is an excellent
call because it turns out a lot of work
is
boring uh so with the system we've been
able to save over a 100,000 hours of
human Fone and calling time and we're on
track to save Millions more in 2025 and
what's really incredible about voice AI
today is that we did this with a really
lean team of four Engineers so building
the whole full stack web application
these EHR Integrations the bot you just
saw all while bringing on new customers
supporting new conversational use cases
really quickly and a big part of why
that was possible was because we really
all embraced this role of a voice AI
engineer so let's kind of uncover what's
unique about a voice engineer today and
what hats they may be wearing so
starting from switch's like original
graft we can kind of see that a voice AI
engineer is going to deal with
multimodal data so MP3s audio bites in
addition to transcripts you're dealing
with transcription models voice models
speech to speech all that sort of thing
the application you're building it's in
real time latency all of a sudden
matters so much more you're going to be
dealing with async and python a lot more
than you probably wanted to be doing and
the product constraint here is almost
always going to be a voice conversation
so people have really high expectations
of how these sorts of conversation goes
uh for us like we're slotting ourselves
into an existing uh sort of like
business interaction and people expect
us to be conversational and fit into
that use case so to Grapple with all
these challenges we kind of have two
sayings at superow that we've been
saying over the past year and a half say
the right thing at the right time and
build this plane while we fly it so the
trickiest part uh for us is customizing
all these scripts and all these use
cases for each customer individually and
then we really
on this kind of like horizontal voice AI
stack to help us out with all those
other problems and this is kind of how
we think about the voice AI engineer
today and its unique roles and in the
larger context we're really at this
inflection point where it's so easy to
build out an MVP for these sorts of
applications that ultimately what is
going to make your voice bot unique
isn't its Voice or its Interruption
handling or how realistic it sounds or
how it does turn taking ultimately it's
going to be in the conversational
content and the design there and the
vertical Integrations around it that
make your agents work actually valuable
and if you're like me and your favorite
classes in college were the AI ethics
ones everything I just said about moving
fast building with generative AI could
raise a few red uh raise some alarms so
it's not hard to imagine how voice AI
apps specifically could be biased
against
people with certain accents with certain
dialects or be really spooky when they
sound so real and then say weird things
so in the US we both like enjoy and
suffer from a lack of AI regulation and
that leaves the onus ultimately on the
AI engineers and leaders in this room to
think about these sorts of problems this
is not going to be like a talk on like
AI safety and ethics but I think for
voice AI specifically with how it's such
like a new of interaction with
artificial intelligence today I think
it's really important how we go about
building it so for AI Engineers when we
go about making tooling and
infrastructure choices uh remember that
like developing AI should be really
accessible and collaborative and the
work that AI does should be for everyone
and a key part of making sure that's the
case is choosing tooling and
infrastructure so that a really diverse
set of stakeholders can be involved in
that process from the start so with the
role of the voice AI engineer kind of
scoped out now let's dive into some of
the last mile problems in voice AI that
we've been dealing with so when we
started out we had a really scrap
together pipeline of like a
transcription model and an llm and then
a touch to speech model uh this was
awesome to get started at but you know
we faced a lot of problems very quickly
and a lot of what we were learning was
not new at all so though the voice
agents we see today are better than ever
voice UI itself is is not that new so
when we were just getting started uh
around a year and a half ago I had the
chance to speak to Kathy Pearl who is a
close family friend and has been working
on uh the ux of Gemini she's been in the
conversation design game for like 20
years or
something uh and back in the day like
voice UI was lots of phone tree design
and then it becomes these Alexa and Siri
type things and now we're just in this
whole new world but a lot of the
principles remain the same and one of
the biggest things that's changed with
developing voice UI is the shift from
prescriptive to descriptive development
so we no longer prescribe what we want
our bot to do over the course of the
conversation by mapping out every
possible direction that it could go
instead we describe what we want to do
and then kind of pray to the Jenner of
gods that it
happens and for this you know there's a
lot of things I talk about with
conversation design but it comes up
really quickly when that becomes your
main interface
one thing for us is when we're asking
these questions you know should we be
really open-ended with it or kind of
constrain the user into selecting from a
list of choices and for us because these
are existing conversations we find it's
often better to just go General hope the
call center representative gives us a
ton of information and then instead of
trying to prevent them from saying the
wrong thing we try to adapt to whatever
they say so Kathy's
recommendation was hire a conversation
designer
if you're thinking about these sorts of
problemss there are experts in this and
if you're just a voice AI engineer and
you want to get started in this kind of
thinking a great recommendation is to do
little table reads so have one person
pretend to be the bot and the other
person to pretend to be a user and the
sort of like transcript that you may
write out by hand
immediately the sort of gaps and
awkwardness of it comes out when you say
these things out loud so knowing all
these things we really decided to work
on our conversations but we had kind of
had to deal with the tech de debt of the
orchestration framework that we had
built so we really hit our stride when
we started using pipe cat for our voice
AI orchestration this is an open source
framework maintained by the guys at
Daily it's really easy to extend and
hack upon which is important for our use
case when we need to do transfers and
stuff um and we make really long phone
calls these can be like an hour and a
half long so a decision for us in
choosing pipat was that we can self host
it and deploy it and scale it how we
want so with some of our like voice
orchestration headaches dealt with we
really wanted to get back to focusing on
our conversations and everything in this
slide for us is really not unique to
voice UI uh and AI so I'm going to kind
of speed over it two interesting
decisions we've made here because we
just have you know an LM in the backbone
uh we chose to own our own open a
endpoint we find this leads to a better
interface with a lot of these new voice
AI tools so behind our open a endpoint
we can kind of route to different models
that are maybe more uh latency
sensitive for all of our generative
responses we route them through this
tool called tensor zero tensor zero is
relatively new they have this nice
framing of llms uh if that quote
interests you I recommend you look them
up and talk to them they're awesome uh
this is like a little open source tool
so you can do whatever you want with it
they give us kind of stretchered and
typed llm endpoints that we can then
experiment with in production so that's
our gateway to our LM and then all of
our logging and observability we
self-host Lane fuse and we self-host
these things also because these are like
healthcare calls we have to be hypoc
compliant that's often an easiest an
easier way to deal with you know the
rapid growth of this space so there we
do like anomaly detection evals and data
sets
so with a good plan in place for our llm
sort of work another big challenge is
our text to speech system so when you
make these sorts of phone calls your
password is basically your name your
date of birth and then your member ID or
something which is like a 12 digigit
Long stren of characters that you have
to be able to communicate over the phone
and something we quickly realized was
that what our llm is outputting is not
necessarily what we want to shove
through through our text to speech
engine and neither of those things may
actually match what's in the recording
so a little example of this and this is
like a personal last mile is that if
you're building me a personal voice UI
application it should say my last name
correctly so my last name is pronounced
kotus most people and most models will
say
kotus but with a lot of new tools out
there this is the syntax this company
called rhyme uses you can spell out the
exact sort of pronunciations you want
and then for things like spelling where
you may have kind of an intuition for
like the sort of pauses and breaks you
might want to use to say a really long
word you can use something like this
little spell function um and then with
all this stuff like because this is
outputting audio btes we usually review
recordings to make sure that this all
sounds okay in addition to checking the
transcripts and to start wrapping things
up I have a couple little mini Last Mile
problems that we've had to deal with oh
and yeah with voice too
models all this sort of rule-based stuff
gets a little more complicated so some
little Min ones uh we used to be called
super bill and we called our bot Billy
because we thought that was a fun name
turns out that's an awful name over the
phone because we would constantly have
these conversations where people were
like hey nice to meet you Billy and we
would say it's Billy not
Billy so yeah think about your persona a
lot dial that in
early uh if you're just starting don't
build from scratch what's going to make
your Bot unique is the conversation and
there's so many new tools out there like
pipe cat that you can use to get a quick
jump start track latency everywhere time
to First Bite for each of your little
processors is the new most important
metric and is something you always kind
of have to keep an eye on uh upgrade
paths this is a big one for us when we
need to make sure we have really high
transcription accuracy so we use deep
for our speech to text engine and we
know that whenever we kind of want to
improve that part of our system we can
work with them to fine-tune a better
model have fallbacks ready it really
sucks when open eye goes down for a
little bit and all of a sudden all the
concurrent conversations you have are
just down the drain so have fallbacks
ready for each part of your stack it's
really easy to set that up with
something like tens to zero there are
lots of other tools that'll help you
figure that out and then end to end
testing this is pretty unique for voice
UI and or voice AI uh it seems like
people are kind of settling on telefony
as a boundary layer to test your Bot
with like an external
service we do a couple different things
the easiest test for us is to create a
kind of fake phone number that just
plays an MP3 if your Bot can't talk to
an MP3 then you probably have bigger
problems next we can kind of create uh a
simulated voice tree with like different
uh like phone tree building tools and
have our bot pseudo navigate it and then
there's lots of generative services like
Koval and V where you can have your Bot
talk to another
bot so some takeaways for a quote
unquote vertical voice AI engineer
choose your stack wisely the better
decision you makes you make here it will
allow you to focus on the things that
are really truly unique to your
conversational experience laser focus on
the last mile because this is where
ultimately you can provide a lot of
value and put your agents to work and
then ride the wave there's so much new
stuff happening in this space and
whenever new models come out you want to
be able to use them quickly and you also
W want to be able to use them safely so
thank you very much I'm excited to talk
to you all and hear about what's so
special about your conversations
[Applause]
[Music]